been a little bit of a struggle for
caprilian last few outings hasn't been
able to get to that fifth inning but he
has the stuff that once he gets rolling
he can really start to dominate a lineup
that'll bring up isaiah connor falafel
so 1-1
this one on the ground up the middle
diving stop kemp quick hop up throw to
first and it pulls olson off the base
kinder felefa beats it out that was
going to be a brilliant defensive play
in some ways it was it's just the throw
was a little offline and isaiah has a
hit taylor harness he makes his eighth
start of the season facing josh harrison
and there is the fastball harrison not
impressed as he hits it right up the
middle for a base hit so harrison aboard
here's marta
and he
hit the bag at second as marty lines the
single the right center so two on nobody
out
here it comes
and it is in the air another pop-up and
this one will drop and it's gonna open
up a shot for a double play and the
rangers get one
the three five four
double play no infield fly it wasn't a
true pop-up and the inning is done
a lot of confusion on the bases we go to
the second no score to finish off the
bottom of the first inning it's runners
at first and second one out a pop-up
that did not get high enough
to call an infield fly rule so nathaniel
picks it up throws it over to the third
baseman and then to
the shortstop isaiah connor falefa for
the very traditional 356 double play
can't
tell you how many times i've seen that
and written that down in the scorebook
and josh harrison i mean what's he going
to do and he's exactly right there's
nothing you could do no score top of the
second inning nathaniel lowe's gonna
leave things off it's a heads up player
just it's a baseball iq play
low strikes out there to open up the
top of the second inning go behind the
body line
so change up there and heim
swings and this is back-to-back
strikeouts for capriles so two out for
nick solac be pretty important as far as
how the rangers feel about their future
next year solace puts a pretty good
charge into this one deep out to left
that one is off the fence and so is
canna
and solak cruises to second base he's in
there with a two out double
his 17th this year
[Music]
let me see struck him 94 mile an hour
fastball
so three strikeouts in the inning for
cabrillo bottom of the second coming up
well pozo who's hitting 290 now with a
home run and nine rbis
see if that
plays a role at all today bouncer third
base line that's a fair ball
and out toward the bullpen and the ball
dude just sort of casually noticed at
the last moment pozo has himself a
leadoff doubles and now here's yani
hernandez the switch hitting third
baseman so now the one strike pitch and
he'll shoot it over third into left
field that's a base hit pozo into third
base they will hold him up
and the throw came back to third
and almost got him izzy with an infield
hit
his first time up 2-2
and he goes after the high fastball and
pokes it through to the right side
pozo's in hernandez got a good start
he's headed to the plate to throw not in
time hernandez gets around the tag and
kinder philippa goes to second base
we'll take a look at the play at the
plate first yeah i think he got in there
pretty easily i don't think they'll
challenge this they will challenge this
never mind oh did he get his hand i
guess maybe there's a chance
for all that there we go
[Applause]
[Music]
well they got it right
hernandez scores on the single by keiner
falefa
and so the rangers indeed have the two
nothing lead
and kind of falefa moving up on the
throw is out there at second base now
for garcia
and he hits this ball sharply that's in
the left field base hit kinder philippa
into third and they will stop him
but he was barreling around as if he was
going to score bases loaded and jonah
heim strolling up to the plate
and jonah heim hits one hard to center
field but martay able to get back there
and make the play connor falefa tags he
scores
garcia moves up to third base as sac fly
by jonah high makes it three to nothing
[ __ ] swing did he go yes he did they
checked with gabe morales so solac
cannot hold up
three runs on four hits for the rangers
bottom of the third coming up texas
three the eight
first pitch to martin is hit sharply
past the second baseman kemp and out
into right center so there are two men
out hernandez remembers struck out on
the play and here's leote tavares
through two pitch and that one lined out
to right field weird angle by pender and
it goes over his head martin is in
tavares with that lightning speed to
third an rbi triple and it makes it four
nothing rangers
elevated fastball this one caught a
little bit more of the play and leyote
turns and burns out that was some effort
from pender but also an awkward angle oh
two gone it brings up the switch hitting
catcher jonah hein
bounces it up the middle that's a base
hit and so once again the rangers have
at least one hit in every inning here's
john gomez leading off against taylor
hearn
to left field and it's hit well martin's
going back shading his eyes at the wall
he leaps and that baby's gone john gomez
gets the a's on the board maybe that's
the start of something it's four to one
13th home run of the year for
eon
he's gonna wake up this sleepy offense
with a home run fastball in keeping the
hands
inside just enough one and two and
here's the pitch swinging in the miss he
struck out chad pinder and there's your
second out of the inning tastes singled
and then
a soft line out to yanni hernandez the
third baseman
and a tough play off the globe of
hernandez
and picks it up but marty's gonna be
aboard four hits now for the a's as matt
olsen steps up and the fish to olson now
and matt hits it to deep right way back
how far is that gonna fly and the as
they're back in the game
off the facade of the second deck
rangers 4 athletics 3. his 34th a
tremendous shot by olsen you know how
the story goes fast balls and real
estate kite location location
location and matt olson
just pays straight cash for a pad out in
the right field
pack your bags only
two tickets all aboard
next stop
pound town
[Music]
all right rangers with a chance to
finish this off now 4-3 as we
have it long last made it to the bottom
of the ninth inning and joe barlow is
out there looking for the save
the pitch
bouncer left side of the infield
hernandez boss close to first in time
and it's a one two three ninth inning
rangers take two out of three in oakland
and it is by far
best road trip of the year for this
rangers team they come home winners
you